the Affordable Care Act the potential
repeal of it the American Health Care
Act this is also one of the biggest
stories over the last 72 hours House
Republicans passed a repeal of Obamacare
with a replacement bill that is a second
iteration of the failed American Health
Care Act which was pulled a few weeks
ago because it was obvious that it was
going to fail in the house the vote was
very close to 17 in favor to 13 against
how on earth did this pass so quickly
Pat well I'm glad you asked it's because
very few of the people that voted for it
actually read it what's in it
we don't know since it was not a public
at the time how many people will lose
health insurance if this ultimately
passes the Senate and is signed into law
by President Trump we don't know since
the vote was taken before the
Congressional Budget Office scored it
how much will this cost we don't know
because they voted before the
Congressional Congressional Budget
Office scored that aspect of it this is
something that Republicans said they
would not do remember when the House
Republican Twitter handle in 2010
tweeted will speaker Pelosi wait for the
final number from the Congressional
Budget Office apparently Republicans
don't need to Paul Ryan from July 29th
of 2009 I don't think we should pass
bills that we haven't read that we don't
know what they cost I guess that only
applies to Democratic bills Paul Ryan
also in July of 2009 we shouldn't rush
this thing through just to rush it
through for some artificial deadline
let's get this thing done right
apparently not
something that applies when it is a
Republican bill this is not an accident
this is deliberate because the responds
the scoring from the CBO would clearly
be a disaster so now what happens well
it goes to the Senate it's going to be
more difficult in the Senate it won't be
impossible to get 51 votes in the Senate
but more than likely if you're going to
get 51 votes in the Senate Pat it's
going to have to be a much cut up and
modified version of what the House
Republicans pass because you've got to
get the same you need moderate
Republican senators
to say that they approve of something
that the extremist freedom caucus tea
party sensitive House Republicans want
and I don't know how you get a bill that
both of those groups say we like what
this does right in theory the Senate
could just take the House bill and vote
on it on the spot but they're not going
to do that they're going to draft their
own bill of course as we know now from
Senator Susan Collins of Maine seems
like they don't like a lot of the
provisions that they have in the House
bill so they're going to have to pass
their own version and then there's a
committee process after that has to go
back into both chambers before it gets
on to president Trump's desk so there's
a lot of steps there which made it
weirder that right after the vote Trump
and House Republicans had a sort of
celebration at the White House and it
was weird for three reasons to be
celebrating one it's weird because as
you're pointing out Pat it needs to pass
the Senate there's going to be changes
it needs to go back voted on committee
Trump etc so it's not the law yet and
it's weird to celebrate just based on
that number two it's weird to celebrate
this if you're Trump and House
Republicans because we don't know what
it will cost because the CBO didn't
score it Republicans claimed to care
about how much things cost so why would
you cheer before you know how much it
costs and number three it's weird to be
cheerleading this thing because unless
this is opposite unless this is the
opposite of the first version of the
bill millions of people are going to
lose health insurance and that's a sort
of depraved thing to be cheering about
in my mind right especially because we
also don't have much public opinion
about this we knew that the original
American Health Care Act had about a
seventeen percent approval rating yeah
we just don't have enough time for this
new version the other difficulty in
general with this type of legislation is
that Obamacare is not very left-wing
it's actually pretty right-wing in a lot
of ways in fact it's based on a plan
that in the 90s the conservative
Heritage Foundation actually developed
and it's something that Republican
governor Mitt Romney approximated with
Romney care here in Massachusetts so
it's very difficult to do something more
conservative than Obamacare without
kicking tons of people off of their
insurance how can you take Obama care
and say we're going to go to the right
and improve on cost care quality and
access it sort of can't be done it
doesn't matter how much Trump says they
fix everything
that's the fundamental big lie Pat which
is that you can't go to the right from
Obamacare and make everything better as
they claim what you could do is cut out
the regulations and strip things like
the Medicaid expansion because you're
right I mean Obamacare at its heart
mandates that you buy private insurance
that's a right-wing plan that was
supported by people like Bob Dole and
yep dang rich and a whole slew of
Republicans George Bush Senior and why
would this be the direction Republicans
want to go because they fundamentally
don't have as their top priorities
improving on cost improving the quality
of care and improving access they don't
believe health care is a right
more and more Americans increasingly
believe health care is a right and for
them up for the for these Republicans
the system they want is a market-based
system where people get and this you
have to interpret this literally
Republicans want a system where people
get the care they can afford period full
stop
you don't need to add anything on to
that and that is not a system that
increases access quality of care or
reduces cost so we will be following
this a lot of our program today we're
going to talk more about what's going on
with health care you can send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman also follow the show on twitter
at david pakman show our newest sponsor
is tag adapt the hosting specialists
hosting specialists based in the UK but
available to you all over the world taga
dev offers affordable and flexible
hosting packages it includes dedicated
servers virtual private servers cloud
server options as well as completely
custom solutions and colocation services
tailored to your specific project I
think that with hosting anybody can just
throw some servers together but really
the thing is support an expertise and
advice taga dab has a nine point seven
out of 10 rating on Trustpilot which
puts them at excellent 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
and that is really their strength you
can get a 10 British pound credit when
you sign up for a cloud server account
today at signup tag
AB comm /t DPS check it out support the
David Pakman show by supporting our
sponsors